[Music]
well hello dear friends Welcome to our
question and answer program I'd like to
know this is one of our favorite
programs here at Secrets unsealed
because we get the chance to answer your
questions what you're thinking and uh
the needs that you have and uh so we are
very pleased that you decided to join us
today we have several very interesting
questions uh let me give you the address
where you can send us your questions
it's an electronic address you'll see it
on the screen
tvom tv.org once again tvsm
tv.org we also request that you have
patience because we receive many more
questions than we can answer uh very
quickly but we put them in order and we
answer them according to when we receive
them so keep them coming keep tuning in
and eventually we will get to your
program to your questions so I have with
me here Pastor David Salazar uh who uh
the CEO of the Spanish work here at
Secrets unsealed he does many other
things besides that he's a contractor
and uh I could uh make a long list of
resumé items but we're very fortunate to
have him with us has the same vision the
same mission of uh upholding the truth
as it is in Jesus and Pastor we're glad
to have you on the program thank you
Pastor Bor it's uh always an honor for
me to spend this time with you here in
the program to answer the questions we
enjoy this program a lot as you
mentioned answering and getting to
respond to the inquiries that those
friends that watch your programs send us
so praise the lord well we should never
begin a program without prayer because
uh only he who inspired scripture is
able to come and explain it to us so
would you pray for us please absolutely
let us pray we thank you Lord as we come
before you before your throne of grace
uh we thank you Lord for allowing us to
come and and and ask you to send us your
holy spirit because we know that we are
limited in understanding we are not uh
able to know all things we lack all the
knowledge but you have all the answers
you have all the knowledge and the Holy
Spirit can be our teacher our guide and
we pray that you will help us today as
we open your word to be used by you to
be students of your word and to be able
to share from your word the answers that
will help those that are watching to
know you and to know the truth to your
qu to their questions so I thank you for
all of this guide us and lead us we pray
this in Jesus Jesus name amen
amen okay we have a question um the
person who sent the question is
anonymous and um I've never gotten this
question before but it's a very
practical one uh this is how it reads I
am a widower with two teenagers renting
living basically check by check trying
to be faithful to God preaching and
waiting for his soon return
when we have to flee from the cities
where and what should I
do I don't have anything or where to go
I do know I should trust God and I do
can you please provide a little guidance
I know like me is a lot of faithful
people in other words there are faithful
people just like this person that
doesn't that don't know what to do when
that time comes
so what can we say to this person who is
asking a very practical question
concerned about the future having to
flee not having anywhere to go uh what
kind of counsel and comfort can we give
to this person well first of all Pastor
I think that we need to um listen to the
words of Jesus that he gave instructions
to those that were in the time of
Jerusalem were to going to face
something similar in chapter 24 of
Matthew verse 15 and 16 he mentions
something specifically he says there
when ye therefore shall see the
abomination of desolation spoken of by
Daniel the Prophet stand in the Holy
Place who soth let him understand then
let them which be in Judea flee into the
mountains so here
Christ mentions using the example of
Jerusalem that those that were watching
for the signs and when they would see
that Abomination desolation that was
going to be seen around Jerusalem when
the Romans armies would come and
surrounder Jerusalem that for them was a
sign that they needed to flee to the
mountains now the word flee means that
you are pretty much leaving everything
behind as a matter of fact verse 17 he
says those that you know have uh they in
the Housetop do not come down to get
anything the house and then that uh not
neither anybody goes back for their
clothes
so he's saying when that sign comes the
fleeing process is basically take what
you have on you and leave and God of
course Jesus was telling them that there
will be probably many people like this
person here who did not have the means
or the uh uh property or something to go
to but she needed or that person or
those that were there in that time they
needed us to follow the instruction of
God in faith and
flee and I believe that the same
principle will be applied to many who in
the last days might be in a situation
where they have not a place to go they
have not been able to buy a place they
have not been able to come out of that
experience of of living in the cities
and they may have to just leave not
exactly knowing where to go it's not
like they were going to have like a
house or a of a area a mountain that
we're going to say everybody goes there
we won't know the Lord will press you
where to go now having said that I do
believe that today the Lord has given us
instructions that we are to start moving
from the large cities to smaller cities
so there is a process of preparing and
starting to move in the right direction
that we need to do now if if our friend
who has given that instruction has
understood this concept that large
cities are not to be a place to dwell we
need to pray and say Lord help me to
find whether a job a place to relocate
sometimes we don't want to leave the big
cities because we are so attached to our
job or to our you know income that we
feel that living that it's it's G to
make us you know unable to sustain
ourselves but I believe that we do
careful planning and we pray to the Lord
he will open a door and he will help you
or help that person move into a smaller
City so that that can be a process of
starting to move in the right direction
uh and ultimately there are people and I
say this because I've met some ter
people who have moved to this to the to
this out of the cities and have mve to
the country and I I know it's particular
two individuals who have actually felt
that the Lord has impressed them to
build extra shelters if you will for the
time comes for somebody that does not
have a place to go for them to come into
that place so maybe the Lord is already
preparing just like these individuals
other places of Refuge if you will and
God will provide you that direction in
the right time if you're following his
instructions yeah and uh really the
fleeing uh takes place primarily before
the close of probation during the little
time of trouble right uh Ellen White has
also given counsel to people in the
church who have the means to get
property in the country right and she
says that they need to make provision
not only for their own family right they
need to make provision for other people
who don't have possessions so that they
can go and live in the same place where
the person who has has money is able to
get a place so uh this is a test of the
stewardship of those who have helping
those who don't have absolutely uh so uh
you know first of all uh we would
recommend to this uh to this dear family
that uh they live frugally mhm M there's
a lot of information that we don't know
here uh you know uh are they in debt um
are they you know are they spending on
things that uh they should that they
shouldn't uh but you know we need to be
frugal and if possible transition as you
said from large city to a smaller City
to the country and uh God is not going
to forsake us absolutely you know God
sees that we're doing our best and uh if
we don't have any place to flee God will
show us amen a place to flee amen uh
he's not going to leave us out in the
cold so to speak absolutely yeah he's
GNA find a way for us
amen okay we have another question uh
this is very
interesting uh why do certain
denominations teach that Jesus was
created uh not only certain
denominations there are some in the
Adventist Church too that's right who
are teaching that Jesus was created so
so why do they teach this
well it's truly
uh a snare of the enemy of Satan to um
make us going into the trying to find
answers to questions that we don't have
really full answers to so a lot of the
things that that come to this conclusion
is because they don't understand the
concept of how Jesus could be the Son of
God and at the same time how was he at
the beginning trying to explain things
that we have not uh real Clarity or that
God has not really revealed to us you
know we know that he's God he's Eternal
like the father but for a lot of them to
try to figure out or try to explain they
make this concept that Jesus had to be
created or was created and the father is
supreme and it's it's really a way for
the enemy from the very beginning how he
had this idea that Jesus was like him he
did not not wanting to you know he was
jealous of Christ Satan was jealous of
Christ and for for Satan his argument
against Jesus or the validity of him as
God has been a point of contention and
so he has used deception has used reason
human reasoning to make people think
that Christ was created and of course
there's like you said there's groups uh
there's a whole church that believes
this way and unfortunately people now in
the Adventist Church also have this
concept idea that Christ was created
that he's not coeternal with God and so
the father and so this is where the
enemy is trying to confuse and take away
the role of Christ as God as Creator and
as truly a redeemer for us a sinful man
so we we I think that c uh the enemy is
really behind is trying to discredit
Jesus as he has done from the
beginning well you know uh Lucifer was
created
right and uh of course he wants
everybody to think that Jesus was
created to make them think that they're
on the level of equality that was his
argument in heaven right was that you
know he's a creature like me so why
should he get special privileges that I
don't get um Adam was
created he was created from the ground
so he's not of the same substance as the
father right because he's of a different
substance he's created Out of the Dust
of the earth mhm Jesus is of the same
substance of the father he if Jesus was
created he can't save us that's the
bottom line because a creature cannot
save us right I have a couple of
statements here from the spirit of
Prophecy which are very
interesting um and there's so many of
them uh let me just choose maybe one or
two uh uh this one is particularly
important with what
firmness and power he uttered these
words now the words that she's referring
to Ellen Way is referring to is where
Jesus said the father and I are one okay
so with what firmness and power he
uttered the words my father and I are
one the Jews had never before heard such
words from human
lips and a convicting influence attended
them
so Jesus spoke them with
conviction for it seemed that Divinity
flashed through Humanity as Jesus said I
and my father are one right The Words of
Christ were full of deep meaning as he
put forth the claim that he and the
father were of one
substance that's important absolutely
they're both of the substance of God
right we are of human substance the
father and the son are the substance of
God so once again uh The Words of Christ
were full of deep meaning as he put
forth the claim that he and the father
were of one substance possessing the
same
attributes the Jews understood his
meaning there was no reason why they
should
misunderstand and they took up stones to
Stone him they realized what Jesus was
claiming he was claiming to be God he
was claiming to be God in the highest
sense of the word right co- substantial
with the father mhm and Pastor you know
it's interesting that a lot of people
today uh use they twist the scriptures
to try to implement this concept you
know oh Christ is called the second Adam
so he has to be created or something
like along the lines or they use other
verses but when we understand that
Christ claimed several times that he was
God and that he and the father were one
uh John in 1 John chapter 2
verse uh 22 it says who is a liar but he
that denieth that Jesus is the Christ he
is Antichrist and Deni the father and
the son whosoever deny the son the same
had not the father but he that
acknowledge the son had the father also
so it's you know he's basically saying
that if you deny that Christ is God If
you deny that the Son of God is is one
with God you are denying the father too
so those that claim that you know they
want to follow God and the father and
and you know they're actually by saying
that Christ is created they're speaking
against God himself the father himself
as they are one and they're both God you
know there's another text uh that is
related to the one in John 10 where
Jesus said I and the father are one uh
that's the one where Jesus said to the
multitude before Abraham was I am I am
he didn't say before Abraham was I was
yeah he said before Abraham was I am
he's claiming to be the being that
appeared to Moses in the burning bush
Ellen White wrote this in Desire of Ages
469 and
470 when Jesus said these words silence
fell upon the vast assembly right the
name of God given to Moses to express
the idea of the Eternal presence had
been claimed as his own by this Galilean
Rabbi he had announced himself to be the
self
existent
one he who had been promised to Israel
whose going forth have been from of old
from the days of
Eternity uh so these are only two
quotations from the spiritual prophecy
that are
absolutely explicit absolutely and of
course we have John 1 verse one through
verse three in the beginning was the
word the word was with God and the Word
was God now what part of that don't you
understand the Word was God exactly and
he is God and if you say anything
different there's no way he can be our
savior absolutely amen praise the Lord
all right so I hope that that helps in
answering that question here is another
one um you want to read the next one
absolutely Pastor let's read this one it
says uh this is from Albert and he is
from Malawi and it's the following
question I hope every one and you're
doing fine in the Lord I am okay we're
thankful that he is okay and he says
recently A friend told me that it will
be the fourth generation around
2025 in reference to the second
commandment when the Lord God announced
his Ten Commandments to the Israelites
in Exodus 20 second commandment in verse
5 mentions the third and fourth
Generations what does forgiveness until
these specific generations mean so
interesting question and interestingly
that someone in telling H or has said
that the four generation ends or comes
to the end around
2025 interesting interesting thought I'm
I'm actually you know wondering what day
they actually started to come to that
conclusion it gives the impression that
uh it's the fourth generation uh since
the giving of the second
commandment I know I don't I don't know
the question is kind of ambiguous right
uh you know uh what relationship does
the fourth generation have to do with
the giving of the second commandment um
I think it's talking about the third or
fourth generation of Any Given person
not since the second command was given
yeah right or maybe because it says 225
maybe he's taking the date of
1865 160 the years I heard of that um
maybe in reference to you know the
somewhere around the time time when the
church was organized well well I you
know interestingly enough this day 2025
maybe is uh in reference to four
generations have passed since the
foundation of the anti Adventist Church
but it's not exactly accurate but anyway
going back to the question what does the
fourth or the Forgiveness to the fourth
and third or third BN generation mean
and so what can we say about this pastor
you know this well want to read a
statement from uh the book The
Patriarchs and Prophets it's the chapter
on the Ten Commandments and it's
addressing directly this commandment all
right absolutely and elen white makes it
clear um this is how it reads page
306 visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children unto the third and
fourth generation of them that hate me
and then she makes this comment it is
inevitable that children should suffer
from the consequence quences of Parental
wrongdoing but they are not punished for
their parents' guilt except as they
participate in their
sins it is usually the case however that
children walk in the steps of their
parents by inheritance and example the
sons become partakers of the father's
sin wrong Tendencies perverted appetites
and debased morals as well as physical
disease and degeneracy are transmitted
as a legacy from father to son to the
third and fourth
generation this fearful truth should
have a solemn power to restrain men from
following a course of sin and then she
comments about the part of of the
question that is not asked uh visiting
uh this is showing Mercy because the
same commandment says showing Mercy unto
to thousands of them that love me and
keep my
commandments so uh you know punishment
is only to the third and fourth
generation but uh for those who love the
Lord It's a thousand Generations his
grace right uh so uh this is talking
about third and fourth generation is
talking about those who participate in
the sins of their parents and God in in
a certain way continues or allows the
the
consequences of those actions of the
Saints to to last till that generation
third or fourth generation but then as
you mentioned the mercy for him for
those that love him it's for millions of
I mean yeah thousands of generations so
we have to emphasize the mercy of the
Lord and some people may feel that I
think might feel identified or may think
that something that happened to them is
because they're been punished by by
their sins but God says actually that if
you love him he'll show mercy so there's
no not necessarily you don't have to
necessarily receive the curse of the
father unless you practice the sin and
love is not commanded right God doesn't
say love
me and you'll be blessed for a thousand
Generations no uh we choose to love the
Lord and the result is God's mercy for
thousand Generations right so the
initiative God takes the initiative in
pouring out his love to us but he wants
us to choose to respond to his love and
love him back and um and this teaches us
how important it is for parents to be
very careful yeah about their their
habits because Ellen White mentions two
things she says by inheritance and by
Example The the behavior or the conduct
of the parents has the impact upon the
children to the third and fourth
generation wow yeah that's something
that we have to really think about and
in regards to Pastor in regards to this
question where he's saying this year
2025 I I think that you have to be very
careful of trying to put some sort of
date uh as to when that four generation
might come I've heard many times people
trying to use that aspect of you know
dates to say oh something's going to
happen after the generation But
ultimately God has not given us that
knowledge or or does not Endor the idea
for us to put a date or a specific time
when uh I don't know maybe the four
generation is finished or whatever it
might be you know he wants us to really
emphasize the fact that we have a choice
today to make right to turn our lives
regardless of what our parents might
have done and I think that collectively
is a church we have seen yes several
Generations past mistakes have made over
and over but God is still expects us to
turn to him even now you know you know
to be part of that final generation to
truly turn to the Lord and to seek him
with all our hearts so that there can be
that fulfillment of Prophecy in in God's
last day people you know the last day
people to be able to show and present
the character of Christ to the world
Amen so I think this is really where we
have to emphasize that God wants to
bestow his Mercy to those that love him
and want to keep his Commandments amen
amen praise the lord well um time is
just about up we don't have time for
another question but um we want to thank
you for joining us for the program I'd
like to know uh please send us your
questions once again the address is TVM
tv.org
once again TVM tv.org we'd be delighted
to get your questions and thank you so
much for joining us we hope to see you
next time on our program I'd like to
know
[Music]